rejoignez-moi sur patreon pour accéder à
l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des coursant visaux
des apérophilos un moyen simple de
soutenir mon travail tout en vous
donnant matière à penser je vous attends
sur patreon le lien est dans la
description salut Fred salut je te
remercie beaucoup d'avoir accepté mon
invitation pour cet entretien c'est le
deuxième entretien qu'on fait sur la
chaîne le premier c'était en 2019 ouais
ça fait longtemps donc ça nous rajogne
pas c'était pour l'éveil des consci
aujourd'hui on se voit pour l'éveil des
consciences 2 avant de commencer est-ce
que tu pourrais te présenter pour ceux
qui ne te connaîtrai pas et nous dire
pourquoi nous sommes ici aujourd'hui
alors moi Frédérique de laaville je suis
youtubeur alors en vérité je suis
youtubeur d'une façon facultative parce
que je suis avant tout auteur je suis
connu pour être un auteur de livres de
musculation vendu dans le monde entier
donc je suis la référence en
bioma pour tout ce qui est musculation
mais aussi sport prépa sportive tout ça
donc biomécanique anatomie appliquée la
connaissance de l'anatomie appliquée au
sport et biomécanique et puis aussi
prévention des blessures d'ailleurs là
on écrit un livre avec mon collègue
Michael gundal un livre sur les
blessures et à côté de ça comme je suis
un homme qui a expérimenté la vie
euh je fais de la philosophie j'écris
des livres de philosophie la philosophie
c'est pas ce qu'on croit c'est quelque
chose qui est c'est pas connaître tous
les philosophes ou avoir fait des études
de philosophie la philosophie c'est
connaître la vie et l'avoir expérimenté
avant tout et c'est pour ça que moi à la
base je suivais pas trop on frais parce
qu'il passait à la télévision et puis là
j'ai vu une vidéo où il disait il
montrait ça sa bibliothèque et j'avais
trouvé ça vraiment touchant et il montre
je sais plus combien il a 12000 livres
quelque chose comme ça il montre sa
bibliothèque vous avez lu tout ça et il
dit mais vous savez
euh c'est beaucoup de temps perdu en
vérité parce que pour être un philosophe
c'est pas que la lecture c'est avant
tout expérimenter la vie et on devient
un philosophe en expérimentant la vie et
j'ai expérimenté la vie dans ses joies
mais aussi dans ses souffrances parce
que j'ai perdu ma femme je sais ce
qu'est la vie donc un philosophe c'est
avant tout quelqu'un qui expérimente la
vie et pas quelqu'un qui recrache comme
un singe savant ce qu'il a lu dans des
livres de philosophie après la
philosophie c'est super intéressant
puisque ça te permet de comprendre le
monde et ça t'avertit sur ces dangers et
sur les possibilités que tu as dans la
vie et et les impossibilités aussi
oui je dis souvent que la pensée c'est
le livre et la vie et que parfois le
livre précède la vie la vie confirme le
livre que les deux sont complémentaires
mais qu en réalité le livre ne peut
jamais remplacer la vie c'està-dire
l'expérience donc toi tu as un pied
disons dans la matérialité du corps du
sport de la biomécanique et aussi un un
pied dans cette activité plus analytique
voire plus spirituel on va en parler
mais avant ça je voudrais faire un petit
préambule pour faire le lien avec ce que
tu viens de dire je sais pas si tuen
souviens quand je t'ai proposé cet
entretien tu m'as dit ok Charles mais tu
sais moi je parle un peu vulgairement
sous-entendu je ne m'exprime pas comme
un philosophe et je trouve que c'est
important de parler de ça parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de gens qui ont encore cette
image de la philosophie comme une
discipline universitaire je dirais même
comme quelque chose de d'assez bourgeois
bourgeois au sens où le la forme va être
privilégié par rapport au fond et ça je
pense que c'est un problème c'est un
problème parce que on peut s'exprimer de
manière très raffiné mais dire des
choses qui sont totalement déconnecté de
la réalité le le raffinement verbal
n'est pas un gage de rigueur ou de
pertinence intellectuelle oui oui
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs c'est ce que
disait Confusius et l' d'ailleurs on
retrouve souvent les mêmes textes dans
confusus et la il disait les les choses
importantes et profondes ne sont pas
forcément belles à entendre il faut se
méfier des gens qui utilisent la forme
tout à fait parce que ça amène à avoir
une image esthétique de la philosophie
et et ça c'est un problème parce que il
y a des choses qui sont vraies et qui
sont désagréable à entendre et que le
fait de s'arrêter à la forme nous fait
complètement passer à côté du fond et
donc j'ai envie de dire à tout le monde
si vous êtes un peu heurté par la forme
des propos de Frédéric aujourd'hui
essayez d'aller au-delà de cet
attachement à la forme essayez vraiment
de vous concentrer sur le fond parce que
vous allez voir qu'il y a énormément de
choses intéressantes dans le discours de
Frédéric et que ça va nous nous éclairer
nous permettre de réfléchir moi le
slogan de ma chaîne c'est donner matière
à penser vous nêtes pas obligé d'avaler
tout ce que va dire Frédéric mais par
contre ça va vous donner matière à
réflexion donc je vous encourage
vraiment à être très attentif durant cet
entretien Fred est-ce que tu as quelque
chose à ajouter par rapport à ça ouais
alors j'ai quelque chose à ajouter c'est
que si ma philosophie ou mon mon
explication parce que la philosophie
c'est tout simplement l'explication de
la vie c'est essayer de de de comprendre
l'existence j'ai une chance alors j'ai
une chance c'est que je ne suis pas un
universitaire c'est une chance parce que
ça me permet d'apporter aussi une un
autre angle de vision je parle comme
Frédéric de laavier qui a
été moulé par mon existence et pas
uniquement par ce qu'on m'a mis dans les
oreilles à l'université ce qui veut pas
dire que ce qu' a à l'université n'est
pas bon bien sûr au contraire mais peut
brider les gens aussi qui auront peur de
dépasser ce qu'ils ont entendu parce
qu'ils se firont trop à ce qu'ils ont
entendu oui des fois se former c'est se
conformer et donc quand on quand on fait
un un processus d'apprentissage
universitaire on peut avoir tendance à
rester un petit peu sous sous la coupe
de cet enseignement qu'on a reçu et
avoir peur de s'en émanciper avoir peur
d'aller expérimenter par soi-même et de
confronter de mettre à l'épreuve du réel
ce qu'on a appris on se voit aujourd'hui
pour parler de l'éveil des consciences 2
qui est ton nouveau livre ce livre où
est-ce qu'on peut se le procurer sur
Amazon alors sur Amazon après je sais
pas normalement il va peut-être être
dans les Fnacs ou alors on peut demander
aux gens aussi de le recommander à leur
libraire pour qu'il le commandent voilà
ce qui se fait aussi parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ne souhaitent pas
et je les comprends commander sur Amazon
donc allez chez votre libraire et
demandz lui de commander lesveil des
consciences leséveill des consciences de
est-ce que tu peux nous dire euh
pourquoi tu as eu envie d'écrire ce
livre quelle est sa jeunesse qu'est-ce
qui t'a donné envie d'écrire ce livre je
pense que l'avenir de l'humanité ne
l'avenir le progrès que l'humanité peut
avoir le dernier le dernier progrès on
va dire humain ça va être l'éveil et
l'éveil c'est de savoir qui l'on est
réellement il y a eu des des gars
formidables des prophètes qui sont
passés qu'on explique Jésus pour ma
quelqu'un d'exceptionnel qui a quand
même diffusé le message du pardon et je
pense pense que après ça il y a un autre
message qu'il faut passer c'est de
savoir qui l'on est vraiment et j'ai
fait justement j'ai fait ces bouquins
pour expliquer qui nous sommes
réellement qui nous sommes réellement au
niveau évolutif c'est évolution
c'estàdire que nous sommes la mémoire
génétique de notre lignée donc des
automatismes de
réaction hérité de nos ancêtres qui leur
ont permis de survivre et que tout cela
fait que nous sommes des êtres
prédéterminés nous pensons être libre de
notre existence mais en vérité nos
pensées surviennent sans que nous en
contre Luu en leur venu généré justement
par cette génétique et cette
confrontation monde qui ont créé des
automatismes de réaction tu vois alors
je vais rebondir là-dessus parce que je
pense que ça résume assez bien le sens
de ta démarche c'est-à-dire de faire la
relation entre le domaine biologique
l'évolution biologique le domaine social
et culturel et même le domaine spirituel
et c'est pour ça que je pense que pour
que nos auditeurs comprennent bien ce
que tu cherches à expliquer je voudrais
si tu me le permets essayer de de
décrire ta démarche je définirai ta
démarche comme celle d'un naturaliste
c'est-à-dire de quelqu'un qui envisage
l'homme comme un animal comme l'animal
qu'il est et on sait que ce qui ce qui
définit la condition animale depuis l'au
de la vie c'est la survie et que l'être
humain n'échappe pas à cet impératif de
survie et donc toi tu as forgé une
grille de lecture grille d'analyse que
je baptiserai la quête énergétique donc
l'être humain comme tous les animaux a
eu besoin d'accumuler de l'énergie il
met en place des stratégies
comportementales très souvent
inconscientes pour optimiser sa quête
d'énergie afin de pouvoir s'adapter à
son milieu et de pouvoir se propager en
se reproduisant l'être humain se se rend
immortel en quelque sorte il combat
contre le temps il combat contre la mort
il se propage dans l'espace et dans le
temps ma question est très simple Fred
comment tu es venu cette grille
d'analyse fondée sur la quête
énergétique parce que j'ai été à la rue
parce que j'ai été un moment clochard
j'ai été hébergé par mon ami Olivier et
j'étais vraiment dans une situation très
dure dire pendant des années j'ai pas pu
me chauffer et j'ai pendant un ou 2 ans
j'ai pas pu manger de viande ce qui
marque un homme alors évidemment comparé
à ce qui se passe en Palestine
actuellement je prends pas parti mais
quand Quand tu es dans la misère de la
guerre ou en Ukraine je prends pas parti
non plus c'est la guerre c'est rien mais
le fait de ne pas pouvoir manger à sa
fin de pas pouvoir se chauffer et d'être
éventuellement à la rue ne pas avoir de
logement là tu comprends que l'essentiel
dans la vie c'est l'énergie et si tu
n'as pas d'énergie tu ne penses pas tu
ne crées pas et tu ne te reproduis pas
et que tout tout être vivant tout
organisme est fait pour prendre une
énergie pour rester en vie
l'échanger tu échanges quelque chose
contre contre quelque chose et la
prendre dans la prédation pour rester en
vie et la redonner aussi pour
transmettre la vie avant de mourir tout
est fait pour prendre
l'énergie et la redonner avant de mourir
pour laisser des individus plus adapté à
ce monde en mouvement que tu ne l'étais
puisque le monde change en permanence la
mort est faite pour pouvoir avoir des
êtres qui à ce moment-là seront plus
adaptés au nouveau monde et en fin de
compte l'important c'est que la vie
continue parce que je dis tout le temps
au niveau spirituel la vie à un certain
niveau accueille l'esprit du monde de
Dieu en l'homme tu vois tout ce monde
n'est fait que pour générer la
conscience c'est-à-dire que l'énergie
initiale est faite pour générer la
matière par crrétion hein qui elle même
va
générer les étoiles les planètes et si
une planète est à une bonne distance
d'une étoile donc ni trop grillé s est
trop près ni trop glacé s est trop loin
elle va à un certain moment il y aura de
l'eau elle va générer la vie et cette
vie peut
éventuellement
générer la conscience la conscience en
l'homme pourquoi l'homme parce que
l'homme est le système le plus efficace
et le plus efficient monde pour pouvoir
accueillir cette conscience cette
conscience qui vient de notre structure
elle-même et du verbe la conscience elle
n'apparaît pas comme ça elle apparaît en
fonction de ce que tu es physiquement on
est lié à la matière l'esprit est lié à
la matière et ça c'est très important de
comprendre le processus qui mène à
l'homme et la conscience la spiritualité
elle est liée à l'homme et à notre
structure et ça ça pas été noté jusqu'à
présent on est vraiment un être
spirituel avec l'éléphant pour le moment
iléléphant et singes une certaine
spiritualité il y a des degrés d'émotion
les les animaux aiment préméditent mais
ne peuvent pas exprimer la préméditation
et la spiritualité c'est le propre de
l'homme voilà la spiritualité alors
qu'est-ce qui définit la spiritualité tu
peux prendre ton temps pour répondre
parce que je pense qu'il faut en
expliquer aussi comment est apparu la
spiritualité chez l'homme et qui a fait
que du coup l'être humain est devenu la
spiritualité elle est basé basée autour
du verbe et des notions de temps
c'est-à-dire que à partir du moment où
tu as des notions de temps dans le
langage tu vas commencer à être un être
spirituel c'est-à-dire avoir la la
capacité de concevoir l'esprit l'esprit
sans le corps et ça ça vient de notre
morphologie à partir du moment où un
petit singe bipède s'est retrouvé en
savane il a pu avec ses mains indiquer
les directions c'est-à-dire où je vais
où je viens indiquer le temps il peut
être dis peine en forêt mais qui a fait
de la forêt moi j'ai fait de la forêt
j'ai fait de la jungle j'ai vécu en
jungle plusieurs mois en jungle il y a
pas de futur et de passé le présent est
partout autour de toi c'est le présent
c'est la canopé tu ne peux pas montrer
où tu vas et où tu viens tu ve dire qu'
y a pas d'horizon qui permet de
d'indiquer l'avenir voilà d'indiquer
l'avenir à partir du moment où un singe
P se retrouve en savane dans un milieu
d'ailleurs très dangereux parce que peut
plus griper aux arbres donc il y a des
fauves qui bouffent des gros herbivores
et il peut être victime de de ces de ces
fauves c'est un milieu très dangereux et
là il est obligé d'aller chercher de la
nourriture il y a moins de nourriture
puisqu'il est pas habitué à bouffer des
graminés il a pas le système digestif
des des ruminants donc il est obligé
d'aller chercher de la nourriture soit
les fruits dans les arbres hein soit
d'aller chercher de la viande il peut
pas chasser donc il va être un chasseur
opportuniste un chasseur la charonniard
opportuniste qui peut bouffer que des
charonnes fraîches parce qu'il a pas le
système digestif des Carnivor pour
pouvoir détruire par une acidité
d'estomac toutes les toutes les
bactéries dans les Charon il risque d'y
passer donc à ce momentlà il se déplace
et il va indiquer où il va et où il
vient il va mettre un son sur ses
gestes je tout le temps caricatural il
va enlever les gestes et il va se
retrouver avec dans son langage des
notions de temps ça veut pas dire que
les autres espèces n'ont pas de notion
de temps sauf qu'elles ne l'exprime pas
c'est différent et la capacité
d'exprimer le temps permet de préméditer
des actions à plusieurs fait tu vois
c'est ça
ouou he c'est futur lion ou
ouou futur gnou ouou je sais pas ou
gazelle tu ils vont ils vont créer un
langage très simple donc ils vont
commencer à créer un vocabulaire donc
des compressions données euh sensoriel
sensori en mot c'est des compressions
c'est une interface sonore pour parler
plus vite parce qu'ils sont vulnérables
hein donc ils peuvent parler plus vite
et ils peuvent préméditer des actions
par justement ces notions de temps qui
permet à plusieurs de préméditer des
actions les chiens il ne préméditent pas
d'action ils peuvent pour eux-mêmes mais
ils ne peuvent pas communiquer ils ont
des façons de de de chasser très simple
avec des traceurs chimiques un chien il
piste dès qu'il sent une proie il va
avoir ses coussinets qui vont générer de
l'adrénaline et l'autre chien voit que
c'est c'est lui qui a et c'est
silencieux qui
a pisté le premier donc il y a une
espèce de communication chimique pas
d'aboiement quand même parce qu'il faut
pas avertir qui leur permet dire tiens
j'ai trouvé mais il y a pas d'expression
réellement du du futur alors que l'homme
est le premier exprimer je vais je viens
je serais j'étais et à ce momentl il
peut pré d'action et enseigner de ce
qu'il a fait et par le verbe enseigner
ce qui permet non plus de uniquement
enseigner par l'exemple comme une maman
chatte peut enseigner à ses petits
comment chasser ou une maman singe
enseigne comment chercher un truc mais
elle peut par le langage et la
compression de données en mots parler de
choses sans les montrer voilà ce qui
permet d'enseigner à un grand nombre
d'individus économiser du temps de
l'énergie et à ce moment-là tu
enclenches un développement du cerveau
pourquoi parce qu'un gros cerveau ça
consomme beaucoup d'énergie ça ne sert à
rien un gros cerveau qui pense trop
lentement ça ne sert à rien donc les
animaux fonctionnent en réflexe
conditionné ils ont survécu à quelque
chose ils l'ont vécu sous émotions ce
qui a vécu sous émotions est tracé dans
le système nerveux dans les connexions
neuronales et va être et tout ça va être
euh quand le corps n'est plus en veille
va être rollicité à la nuit pour que ta
mémoire vécue sous émotion se consolide
dans ton cerveau tout en évacuant tout
ce qui n'a pas d'intérêt autrement tu un
fata dans le cerveau qui ne servira à
rien donc tous les tous les soirs quand
tu t'endors ton ton organisme détruit
les connexions neuronales qui ne serent
à rien fait le tri et ne conserve que
Cell qui ont été vécu par sous émotions
donc les plus les plus intéressantes
pour la survie tu vois et ce langage
permet de penser beaucoup plus vite à
partir du moment où tu peux avoir cette
interface sonore qui te permet de penser
beaucoup plus vite tu peux réfléchir en
permanence même quand tu es repos on on
a étudié les singes les électrons
sphalogramme de singes on s'aperçoit
qu'on repos ils pens pas ça ne sert à
rien ils ont pas cette interface sonore
ça consommerait trop d'énergie pour rien
tu vois alors que l'homme peut se faire
plein de scénarios par le langage quand
tu penses maman tu dis Maman mais si tu
veux approfondir maman tu ralentis ta
pensée à ce moment-là c'est comme un
système informatique tu vas à ce
moment-là visualiser maman sentir maman
toucher maman ta pensée se ralentit mais
c'est pas efficace pour aller à la quête
énergétique il faut qu'il cette
interface sonore qui permet de
communiquer rapidement et ces notions de
temps et cette compression de donné en
mot te confronte
obligatoirement au fait de parler du
futur et de te confronter à la mort
c'est c'est la boîte de Pandor c'est
l'angoisse qui na de la finitude mais
comme ces notions de temps ces
compressions de données te permettent de
projeter spirit
uellement dans un passé mémoriel dans un
futur hypothétique mais aussi en
d'autres en d'autres lieux et d'autres
temps tu es capable de concevoir
l'esprit sans le corps c'est le verbe
qui te permet de concevoir l'esprit sans
le corps le verbe
et nait la spiritualité humaine parce
que tu te projettes à la fininitude là
tu es angoissé tu souffres
et ta façon de te calmer c'est dire mais
si ce que j'envoie en mon esprit que
j'envoie dans d'autres lieux et d'autres
temps par la
pensée cet esprit peut peut-être
survivre après ma mort et et la
décomposition des chair et du corps et à
ce momentl naî la spiritualité donc
l'esprit des ancêtres je ne vais pas
mourir puisque j'ai un esprit que je
projette par le
verbe mon esprit
et c'est pour ça qu'on voit toutes les
les représentations des des divinités
des esprits sont souvent aé ou des
oiseaux il y a une très belle je crois
que c'est àasco on voit un homme
mort il est en érection al il est en
érection parce qu'il y a peut-être une
fracture de du rachis c'est connu hein
cré une érection il a je crois un bison
éventé à côté et on voit un oiseau
l'oiseau évidment un symbole d'esprit il
est mort mais son esprit est là prêt à
s'envoler puisque l'Esprit vole il vole
par la pensée donc on a toujours
assimilé l'esprit à quelque chose de
volant il est dans les airs c'est arien
oui ça aérien l'esprit ça aérien
puisqu'on se projette nous-même par ce
verbe dans dans le temps au commencement
était le Verbe
c'est la la spiritualité naî avec le
verbe et à chaque progrès
linguistique des mutations entraînant
une prolifération neuronale
devienneent efficace parce qu'avant
c'est de la consommation pour rien plus
tu as d' d'til linguistique plus tu peux
penser rapidement efficacement et
communiquer efficacement et rapidement
et transmettre aux génération futures
d'où le fait que l'homme soit un animal
historique et culturel comme disait
Harari voilà alors Harari avait fait la
très bonne analyse que c'était un animal
historique l'homme est un animal
historique et ça on peut lui reconnaître
ça mais c'est un universitaire qui n'a
pas ma formation et moi j'ai expliqué
pourquoi c'est un animal historique
c'est un animal historique parce qu'il
est bipède voà et il indique les
directions et naî à ce moment-là des
notions de temps dans le langage et
l'humanité la pierre de fondation de
l'humanité c'est le c'est pas le langage
tu les animaux c'est le verbe et les
notions de temps et à partir de ce
moment-là se construit l'humanité autour
du langage et autour des outils
linguistiques plus tu as d'outils
linguistiques plus tu as de mutation
entraînant des proliférations neuronales
qui consomment énormément
d'énergie mais qui en rapporte encore
plus d'où l'expansion de l'humanité très
bien je voudrais qu'on récapitule un peu
parce que ça a été extrêmement dense ce
que tu viens de nous expliquer la
trajectoire qui conduit ce petit primate
bipède à devenir l'homme c'est
c'est-à-dire un animal spirituel il y a
d'abord un redressement de l'homme même
s'il n'est pas encore homme à ce
moment-là sur ces deux pied qui va
libérer les mains de la fonction de
locomotion c'est-à-dire un animal bipède
bien il a ses bras libres le seul bipède
tu me reprends si je me trompe qui n'a
pas cette capacité ce sont les oiseaux
puisque les oiseaux sont bipèd mais pas
les bras mais non pas les bras pour
indiquer les aut très très intelligent
he c'est ça on parle pas il prémédite
hein oui oui oui on fait pas de
hiérarchisation c'est simplement l'étude
des spécificités donc l'être humain se
retrouve finalement avec deux membres
libres qui vont lui permettre d'indiquer
des directions ces directions vont
ensuite se convertir en notion
temporelle et donc le langage combiné
aux notions de temps permet à l'homme de
concevoir l'esprit séparé du corps c'est
ça que tu que tu nous expli
partant de là l'esprit devient pour
l'homme une entité qui existe
indépendamment de lui VO d'où la
conception qu'on avait dans la haute
antiquité de l'âme qui survit à la mort
du corps faut savoir que la philosophie
telle qu'on telle qu'on la conçoit elle
est née en Grèce aux alentours de 500
600 avant Jésus-Christ mais qu'on trouve
dans les textes des pyramides en Égypte
oui les Égyptiens l'avaent égyptiens
tout le monde on trouve également ça
dans les les Vedas en Inde c'est-à-dire
cette conception métaphysique de l'être
humain et de l'âme humaine donc cette
idée qu'il existe quelque chose dans
l'homme qui survit à la mort du corps
mais même chez les animistes chez tout
le monde VO le l'homme depuis qu'il est
homme depuis qu'il est bipède et qu'il a
ses notions de temps commence à générer
cette spiritualité il est évident que la
spiritualité est liée à l'homme et est
lié aux notions de temps et les notions
de temps sont liées à la bipédie en
savane tu peux être sûr que tu es qu'un
australopithèque est en savane il a
cette capacité de pointer et d'indiquer
les directions et même les singes long
là j'avais un ami qui était au Cameroun
et avec les les pigmets les pigmet sont
des chasseurs et ils avaient combattu
des des chimpanzés et on voit qu'il a
quand même préis de cette spiritualité
chez nos cousins qui ont les mêmes
ancêtres que nous attention ils sont pas
si éloignés hein et ils avait blessé tué
un un chimpanzé et blessé un autre et
ils ont retrouvé ce corps de chimpanzé
qui avait été mis le long d'un arbre et
recouvert de branchage par son collègue
donc il y a quand même cette
compréhension de la mort chez nos
cousins et des prémises de spiritualité
tu vois sauf que chez l'homme du coup
c'est verbalisé voilà et donc ça ça a
fait de de l'homme cet animal spirituel
qui s'est hissé au sommet de la chaîne
alimentaire grâce à ses à ses capacités
cognitives qu'on ne retrouve pas au même
degré dans les autres espèces animales
est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer en
quoi ce caractère spirituel de l'être
humain est un avantage évolutif
également un avantage en terme de survie
par rapport au autres espèces alors la
spiritual plus le langage la
spiritualité permet d'enlever l'angoisse
de la mort de créer des religions
c'est-à-dire que en nous unifiant
derrière une croyance déjà on enlève nos
angoisses et après derrière cette
croyance on va y mettre des rites c'est
Confusius qui disait le plus important
c'est les rites c'est pas la réalité de
la religion en elle-même les histoires
qu'elle véhicule mais c'est la loi les
lois qu'il y a dans ces religions et les
rites qui sont associés qui permettent
d'unir les hommes derrière des croyances
et derrière des rites et à ce moment-là
il y a les fêtes il y a des des jours
d'union et on on crée un groupe plus uni
par des pratiques communes donc une
fonction sociale la religion d'ailleurs
religaré c'est relié et le débat est de
savoir si c'est relié les hommes entre
eux ou relié l'homme à Dieu et en
réalité c'est les deux en vérité c'est
relié les hommes entre eux la religion
est faite pour unifier les hommes et
permettre aux groupes humains unifiés
d'être plus résistant et de protéger les
individus qui le constitue puisque
l'homme est un animal social incapable
de vivre seul c'est pas un ours donc
quand il est seul il meurt il est obligé
d'être relié à un groupe donc la
religion est un liant derrière des
histoires histoire mythique d'un ancêtre
mythique hein histoire en plus c'est un
calement et ça permet à notre au groupe
humain d'être plus résistant et ainsi de
pouvoir plus facilement transmettre la
vie et transmettre les gènes et alors la
transition est toute faite parce que à
la fois la religion a une fonction de
socialisation et de renforcement du
groupe mais on constate aussi en tout
cas forceé d'admettre par rapport à
l'histoire que on s'affronte beaucoup au
nom de la religion il y a des guerres au
nom de la religion et toi si j'ai bien
compris ce que tu dis c'est que
finalement on ne s'affronte pas pour
défendre une cause religieuse la
religion n'est que le vêtement du
conflit qui a des origines beaucoup plus
primitivesou est-ce que tu peux nous
expliquer quel sont les origines des
conflits les les origines des conflits
alors les conflits ne sont jamais
religieux c'est un prétexte ils ne sont
ni politiques les conflits sont
énergétiques toujours énergétiques on
est des organismes faits pour prendre
l'énergie pour rester en vie et ensuite
transmettre cette vie et ça demande
beaucoup d'énergie hein et tous les
conflits que l'on a
sur terre sont des conflits énergétiques
en réalité la religion permet d'unir des
groupes pour faire valoir leurs intérêt
énergétique tu regarde en Ukraine c'est
des conflits pour les terres noires et
le passage des gazoducs et l'accès à la
mer Noire pour la Russie qui est un
débouché sur la Méditerranée hein avec
une concurrence qui pourrait être avec
celle de l'Amérique qui perdrait
peut-être une hégémonie dans le coin et
qui verrait peut-être une Union
européenne ce sont toujours des conflits
énergétiques et c'est pas des conflits
culturels ou religieux sû toutes les
grandes guerres dans l'histoire a été
des guerres d'invasion qu'ensuite on a
baptisé colonisation mais le principe
est exactement le même quand les
Portugais les Espagnols débarquent en
Amérique au à la fin du 15e siècle c'est
pour étendre leur territoire c'est pour
exploiter des ressources en profiter
aussi pour exploiter et ben les
indigènes qui sont sur place et en
réalité la religion chrétienne à ce
moment-là n'est qu'un drapeau et on on
christianise de force mais derrière le
but il est la conquête territoriale la
conquête des ressources donc on est bien
dans une le énergétique on est toujours
dans une le énergétique et les religions
permettent de renforcer des groupes pour
pouvoir payer d'autres ou de renforcer
un groupe pour pouvoir lutter contre des
pillages mais s'il y avait pas de
religion les conflits internes au
groupes humains feraiit encore plus de
morts et ne permettrait pas aux
civilisations de se développer puisque
s'il n'y a pas d'union entre les hommes
la disparition des sociétés et on vit
dans des dans des mondes où il n'y a
plus de morale où on peut per le voisin
où il n'y a plus de croyance en un
paradis ou un enfer donc on ne va plus
être régulé hein on va dire j'ai faim
bon je vais voler le voisin j'ai envie
de baiser je prends la femme du voisin
et puis on voit ce que ça va mener donc
vengeance meurtre un système de
régulation qui permet à l'humanité de
survivre et de se structurer et de se
développer mais qui qui génère aussi des
groupes humains beaucoup plus structurés
qui à ce momentl vont s'affronter en
guerre mais les guerres entre peuple
font beaucoup moins en vérité vont faire
beaucoup moins de morts que les luttes
internes entre groupes humains qui ell
empêche le groupe humain de se
développer oui c'estd qu'il y a deux
regards possibles sur la religion c'est
de voir le verre à moitié plein ou à
moitié vide à moitié vide c'est de dire
la religion crée la guerre elle crée du
conflit parce qu'elle crée la divis toi
ce que tu dis c'est oui on peut dire ça
aujourd'hui parce que finalement on vit
dans une société en tout cas nous en
France en Europe relativement pacifié
par rapport à d'autres régions du monde
et par rapport à l'histoire mais qu'en
réalité s'il n'y avait pas cette
régulation sociale par la religion le
conflit serait permanent
oui permanent la la
nature élimine d'office ce qui n'est pas
favorable à la vie si si la religion on
s'est développé dans toutes les
populations humaines même qui ont évolué
de façon différente c'est qu'elle est
utile autrement que ça tous les les
principes culturels qui émanent du
biologique ou biologique qui ne sont pas
favorables à la vie sont éliminé
irrémadiablement au bout au bout de de
quelques temps ou de quelques
générations donc si ça s'est conservé
c'est que c'est utile la question est où
on y a répondu bien sûr donc c'est très
intéressant tu appliques
au phénomènes culturels sociaux et
religieux la grille d'analyse
évolutionniste c'est-à-dire que ce qui
n'est pas favorable à la vie est éliminé
pour ça d'ailleurs que souvent on te
reproche d'avoir des positions qui ne
sont pas totalement compatible avec la
l'air du temps idéologique actuelle qui
est plus dans
l'inclusivité oui parce que la nature
n'est pas inclusive elle est exclusive
par définition la nature exclut tout ce
qui n'est pas adapté elle élimine voilà
elle est
elle conservera que ce qui est que ce
qui est utile à la vie et ce qui est
utile à la vie peut parfois paraître
immoral ce que je retiens là de ce que
tu viens de dire c'est que nous sommes
ce que le monde fait de nous je crois
d'ailleurs que c'est une phrase de ton
livre nous sommes ce que le monde fait
de nous autrement dit quand tu analyses
l'être humain son évolution et son
comportement tu ne juges pas l'être
humain tu dis nous sommes tous ce que le
monde a fait de nous et ça ça se traduit
dans certaines constantes niveau des
comportements et je dis ça pourquoi
parce que tu t'intéresses entre autres à
une question qui est celle des
différences entre hommes et femmes et
doncah tu tu expliques qu'il y a des
différences entre hommes et femmes qui
sont biologiques au départ mais qui
étant biologique ne sont pas que
biologique hein je pense que nos
auditeurs auront commencé à comprendre
que pour toi le biologique c'est le
fondement et que le social le culturel
et le spirituel c'est le prolongement du
biologique du BI il y a pas un arrêt il
y a pas des mes différents ex voilà il y
a pas une
indépendance du naturel et du culturel
du biologique et du social il y a une
extension un prolongement de l'un dans
l'autre une interaction et une
interaction la culture modifie modifie
la nature la biologie ta biologie et ta
biologie génère la culture selon toi la
division des rôles sociaux ou des rôles
domestiques entre hommes et femmes dans
l'histoire cette division des rôles
est-ce qu'elle est arbitraire est-ce
qu'elle a été imposée par l'homme ou
est-ce qu'elle a une autre origine non
elle est imposé par le milieu en luiême
et pas par l'homme le problème c'est
qu'on a un petit à croissance lente gros
cerveau dans on est une espèce sociale
extrêmement complexe et il faut plus de
10 ans 15 ans VO 20 ans VO 35 en Europe
ils sont immatures très tard chez nous
mais maintenant ils sont ils sont
tellement immatures qu' fin reproduire
mais on va dire que la bipédie en savane
quand elle est elle est arrivée a rendu
les femmes ex les femelles si tu veux on
dire les femmes extrêmement vulnérable
même si une femme australopythèque ou
une femelle on s'en moque mais on met
des on met des des frontières mais en
vérité tout ça se passe une face
continuum continuum et le fait d'être
bipède en savane avec des gros
prédateurs un petit que tu portes dans
les bras et non sur le dos donc on n'a
pas la taille encore assez marquée aux
arbres encore fait que les femelles sont
extrêmement vulnérables par rapport au
mâles donc les femelles sont obligées de
rester près des arbres près des points
d'eau prêt à grimper aux arbres en cas
où les prédateurs arrivent tu vois donc
elles sont obligées de rester près des
arbres donc elles n'ont pas accès à
beaucoup de nourriture à ce moment-là ce
sont les hommes les mains
libérées qui peuvent partir chercher de
l'énergie les voles de votour au loin
pour trouver une une charoune fraîche
pour pouvoir aller chapardé des EOS un
peu de de charogne eux ils mangent sur
place et puis ils vont ramener des EOS
avec de de la moelle dedans c'est très
énergétique c'est pas que le muscle le
muscle c'est bien mais il il y a
beaucoup d'autres choses le collagène le
le les acides gras essentiels qu' dans
la moelle tout ça c'est extrêmement
c'est des bombes énergétiques pour les
ramener aux femmes qui elles ne peuvent
plus
s'aventurer dans la à l'extérieur pour
chercher des dignames pour chercher des
racines pour chercher à manger par parce
qu'elles ont des bébés elles sont
extrêmement vulnérables et il y a pas
d'arbre pour se réfugier donc ce système
fait qu'un groupe de mecs part avec des
bâton ils sont extrêmement dangereux
hein parce que armé de bâton à plusieurs
ils deviennent à ce momentl des proies
dangereuses pour les prédateurs ils
finissent par ne plus être trop chassés
he ils ont fait des études ils sont
aperçu que c'était des groupes de 10 15
qui était le plus 10 15 20 qui était
plus efficace en groupe de mec en groupe
de mâle ils ont fait des études
caloriques donc ce que j'avais dit éta
était juste hein passer plus d'individus
c'est pas efficace parce qu'il y a pas
assez de nourriture tu vois mais c'est
des groupes de 15 20 qui se déplacent
qui vont chercher la nourriture 15 20
petits singes avec des bâtons et des
cailloux même si ça vise mal et ça et ça
tape mal ça tape fort et ça lance fort
même s'il a pas de précision parce qu'il
continue à grimper aux arbres donc ils
ont pas ils ont pas les fléchisseurs des
doigts tendus ne peuvent pas euh affiner
les les lancé mais c'est extrêmement
dangereux et ça tape très fort donc il
ramène la nourriture aux femelles et
commence l'attachement des mâles aux
femelles un attachement affectif échange
sexe contre nourriture et attention donc
sexe contre sexe et épouillage tu vois
le fait de se faire caresser épouiller
qui permet de créer un lien entre le
mâle et la femelle qui oblige le mal par
dépendance affective à aller rechercher
la nourriture pour la femelle en groupe
donc au départ il y a une vulnérabilité
de la femelle par rapport au Mâ c'est
bien de parler en terme de malâ et de
femelle parce que comme ça en
animalisant on va peut-être moins choqué
les les auditeurs qui qui pourrai être
et du coup tu développes tu développes
des façons de penser différentes tu vois
l'homme est plus dans la conquête du
monde et la dépendance affective la
femme est plus dans la la dépendance
énergétique aux hommes donc une
meilleure compréhension de la
psychologie masculine et du groupe pour
pouvoir gérer des interactions sociales
et récupérer dans ses interactions
sociales un maximum d'énergie alors
puisqu'on parle des relations de femme
on peut enchaîner sur ce qu'on appelle
les stratégies reproductives parce que
je trouve un un point commun
philosophique entre ton livre et ce que
nous dit
Schopenhauer sur le fait que nous
recherchons à travers l'autre sexe
lorsque nous sommes amoureux en réalité
être amoureux ça veut dire percevoir
dans l'autre le meilleur partenaire de
reproduction c'est-à-dire celui avec
lequel on estime qu'on a la meilleure
chance d'avoir une descendance viable et
optimale du coup j'aimerais que tu nous
expliques qu'est-ce que la femme idéale
pour l'homme qu'est-ce que l'homme idéal
pour la femme alors moi moi je suis un
scientifique d'un sta je rigole avec mes
copains scientifique j'ai dit moi je
suis un scientifique d'unsta et un sta
c'est assez formidable pour
avoir une vision du monde en
image très intéressante pour comprendre
beaucoup de choses et aussi beaucoup
d'interviews qui peuvent paraître
ridicule mais qui sont extrêmement
intéressants pour comprendre la nature
humaine et là on voyait un jeune qui
interviewit dans une salle de gym des
filles et des garçons et il pose la
question à une fille vous préférez un
homme intelligent et obèse ou un homme
bête et musclé et aux hommes il disent
vous préférez une une fille intelligente
et obèse ou une fille bête et belle et
toutes les filles répondent on préfère
un homme obèse mais intelligent parce
qu'il pourra maigrir la réponse n'est
pas là en vérité mais inconsciemment
elles sont compris es sont très elles
ont une
intelligence les femmes beaucoup
d'hommes ne comprennent pas et les
hommes disent bah moi moi je veux une
belle je m'en fous qu'elle soit
intelligente si elle est auèse je peux
pas ce qui est normal et en vérité tout
ça ce sont des programmations
programmation génétique pourquoi la
femme elle préfère un homme intelligent
les femmes sont très portées sur
l'intelligence même quand elles ne le
sont pas elles savent la D chez l'homme
donc elles vont rechercher un homme
intelligent avant toute chose parce
qu'il est capable d'aller chercher
l'énergie pour elle et ses petits par
contre l'homme ce qu'il va rechercher
chez la femme c'est sa beauté et sa
beauté c'est ça c'est-à-dire sa
fertilité ça c'est très important parce
que quand tu parles de la beauté tu ne
parles pas des goûts subjectifs en
matière de beauté c'est la bonne
conformation pour pouvoir donner la vie
voilà tout simplement la beauté c'est
quoi c'est la bonne conformation pour
pouvoir donner la vie donc ça veut une
taille fine c'est pas rempli de gras
elle a pas un problème hormonal qui fait
que elle a un gros bide avec de la
graisse viscérale dans dans le BIT ça
c'est des hommes en général
elle a de bonnes fesses un peu grasses
bah c'est de la graisse pour nourrir
bébé he un bassin une taille marquée un
bass une taille fine un bassin un peu
plus large ce qui permet de dire ah
benah un petit il le sait pas il le
ressent programé c'est inconscient parce
qu'elle pourra faire tir à ce moment-là
un petit à grosse tête avec un gros
cerveau hein qui pourra être un homme
intelligent plus tard si rempli de
bonnes choses ce cerveau
dessin tu vois en plus pour donc
pourourir toujours cette idée
d'optimisation et ce qu' veut dire aussi
c'est qu'elle un bon taux d'estrogène
donc elle est fertile tu vois et puis le
visage féminin c'est-à-dire elle a pas
de poil au au menton donc pas de testo
hein donc elle va elle est plein
d'estrogène elle a les lèvres
pulpeuses et rouge la peau la peau plus
plus blanche en Europe bien sûr en
afriqueou après ça se décline selon les
ethnies pourquoi la peau blanche parce
qu'en Europe tu a pas beaucoup de
luminosité donc la femme c'est les
premières à faire des carences en
vitamine D hein puisqu'elles vont
allaitter hein et es ont besoin de
beaucoup de calcium donc elles ontp
besoin d'avoir plus de vitamine D parce
qu'elles vont plus avoir de déficit
calcium lors de l'allaitement hein donc
ça c'est ça c'est vraiment blanchi au
Néolithique hein les nertalien étent
déjà blanc l'homme est attiré par une
certaine forme de femme hein qui est
comm à toutes les femmes donc taille
fine gras sur les fesses poitrine lèvres
pulpeuses pas de poil au menton cheveux
cheveux longs long cil tous les signes
de la jeunesse et de la fertilité parce
que c'est ça qui permet à l'homme de
transmettre ses gènes donc la beauté
pour l'homme on parle d'archétype éid
est fondamental et non pas superficiel
comme on pourrait le croire et la beauté
correspond à la bonne conformation pour
donner la vie donc autement dit la
beauté c'est ce qui favorise la vie la
beauté c'est ce qui favorise la vie pour
la femme et chez l'homme la beauté alors
c'est l'intelligence qui prime mais un
corps musclé un corps en bonne santé
attire aussi les femmes puisqu'il est
capable d'aller chercher l'énergie oui
c'est un signe de bonne santé et donc de
capacité à ramener l'énergie ramener
l'énergie et protéger la femme voilà et
tu dis à un moment dans ton livre une
phrase que j'aime beaucoup tu dis entre
un bon gars riche et et un bon gars
pauvre il vaut mieux un bon gars riche
mais entre un connard riche et un bon
gars pauvre il vaut mieux un bon gars
pauvre dans tous les cas éviter les
connards ah oui oui c'est la base c'est
la base c'est l'histoire du fils de
riche dégénéré tu vois mais le fait
d'avoir cette volonté d'aller conquérir
le monde c'est aussi un
avantage pour la descendance qu'elle
aura c'està-d qu'elle aura pas une
descendance de ramolo incapable d'aller
chercher l'énergie ils auront au moins
cette volonté la volonté ne dépend
dépend aussi de ta génétique le problème
c'est qu'on dit réussir dépend de la de
ta volonté oui mais le problème c'est
que ta volonté ne dépend pas que de toi
elle dépend aussi de ta génétique et de
ta capacité à laavir tout à fait et ça
c'est important de le dire et moi je dis
tout le
temps ce qu'un homme a de plus dur à
surmonter des fois c'est sa
programmation génétique s' s'aperçoit
qu'il est sans volonté et sans énergie
c'est très dur il va devoir essayer de
combattre ça et certains y arrivent tu
vois mais ils partent quand même avec un
sacré inconvénient un
sacré handicap un sacré handicap alors
Fred je t'ai préparé un petit jeu qui va
être interactif donc nos auditeurs vont
pouvoir jouer avec nous est-ce que tu as
lu Nietsche euh oui ou oui parce que
figure-toi que j'ai relu humain trop
humain de Nietzsche j'ai eu euh la
sensation que vous aviez deux points
communs premier point commun c'est au
niveau du style d'écriture une écriture
assez percutante et aussi en aphorisme
parce que c'est quelque chose que tu
fais souvent et Nietzsche le fait dans
certains de ses livres il écrit en
aphorisme et j'ai trouvé aussi que sur
le fond vous partagiez certaines idées
au point que je me suis même dit en
lisant certains passages de Nietzsche
Fred aurait pu l'écrire tu sais quel est
le prénom de Nietzsche euh Nietsche
attends Nietsche nietche min
nom je suis je suis fatigué le le prénom
de Nietzsche c'était Friedrich ah oui
c'est Friedrich j'avais oublié donc bah
fréérick en français et donc j'ai créé
un petit jeu qui s'appelle Fred ou Fred
le but du jeu est très simple je vais te
lire une phrase et tu vas me dire si
c'est toi Fred qui a écrit cette phrase
ouais ou si c'est Nietzsche et si c'est
Nietzsche tu me diras si tu aurais pu
l'écrire voilà d'accord tu es prêt alors
je peux te sortir la ma phrase préférée
de Nietzsche par contre au début alors
elle vient de par de bien mal et je
trouve ça d'une grande profondeur c'est
bonne ou mauvaise la femme aime le bâton
ah il faut pas sortir ça à tout le monde
mais c'est de Nietzche ça plante le
décor alors on y va première phrase
alors attends un tout petit peu avant de
répondre que les auditeurs et le temps
de jouer aussi de leur côté je n'espère
rien j'attends j'agis j'échoue ou je
réussis tel est le bon chemin Fred ou
Fred Fred oui c'est toi qui a écrit ça
deuxème phrase il n'y a aucune loi à la
guerre des lois pour tuer des hommes de
qui se
moque-t-on
alors ça doit être de moi mais il faut
savoir que Tolstoy dit la même chose
mais en plus long d'accord et ben
effectivement c'est de toi donc tu as
gagné ce point 3è phrase l'héroïsme
consiste à faire quelque chose de grand
sans se sentir en concurrence avec les
autres nietzs c'est de Nietzsche est-ce
que tu aurais pu écrire ça
non c'était pas trop dans dans c'est pas
trop dans ma mentalité moi j'ai j'ai dit
toujours le héros c'est celui qui
accepte de se sacrifier pour le bien
bien sûr pour le groupe quand personne
ne le sait d'accord alors phrase
suivante les femmes veulent servir et
ils trouvent leur bonheur les esprits
libr ne veulent pas être servis et il
trouvent leur bonheur niets c'est de
Nietsche est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que tu aurais pu écrire non non niet
c'est nietzs on a des points communs
mais pas partout dans la façon d'écrire
peut-être alors j'hésité avec une autre
phrase de Nietzsche qui dit si hautement
que les femmes respectent leur mari
elles respectent encore plus les
puissances et les idées reconnues par la
société vrai ça tu aurais pu l'écrire ça
j'aurais pu l'écrire très bien si
l'amitié unit les hommes miséreux bien
souvent elle disparaît quand l'un d'eux
réussit c'est Nietzsche ou c'est de toi
[__] c'est toi qui a écrit ça à la
virgule près ah [__] je suis bon donc
tu veux que je la relise peut-être ouais
je suis fort alors je vais dire à quoi
je reconnais que je suis vraiment bon
c'est quand je lis un texte [__] le
mec qui a écrit ça il est bon et on me
dit c'est toi oh
[__] donc je la relis si l'amitié unit
les hommes miséreux bien souvent elle
disparaît quand l'un d'eux réussit ça
sent le vécu phrase suivante notre
époque ne supporte qu'une seule espèce
de riche ceux qui ont honte de leur
richesse Nietzsche c'est de Nietzsche
est-ce que tu aurais pu l'écrire oui et
non ça doit correspondre à son époque
c'est plus le mot époque qui t'a fait
comprendre que c'était de Nietzsche oui
et puis c'est maintenant ils s'en
foutent si j'avais dit notre pays ne
supporte qu'une seule espèce de riche
ceux qui ont honte de leur richesse en
parlant de la France ils font semblant
d'avoir honte en réalité pour se faire
aimer des pauvres phrase suivante se
sacrifier pour les autres telle est la
morale que l'on Martelle aux esclaves
depuis leur plus jeune
âge c'est Nietzche mais ça pourrait être
de moi c'est de toi ah ouais voilà ça ça
aurait pu être de N ça aurait pu être de
ça ça app de je cherchais Dieu plein de
colère je l'ai trouvé je me suis trouvé
j'ai perdu ma colère c'est moi c'est le
toi est-ce que tu peux expliquer cette
citation bah c'est ça s'appelle
l'illumination ou l'éveil c'est-à-dire
que quand tu comprends qui tu es
vraiment et comment fonctionne le monde
tu cherches Dieu en disant mais ce monde
est infemme ce monde laisse là j'ai
jeunes récemment ou des moins jeunes qui
me disaient et les Mornés les enfants
qui souffrent
oui mais je dis tout le temps mais
aurais-tu fait mieux tu vois c'est
surtout ça c'est le monde il est fait
pour vivre et il est fait pour être
relevé c'est à toi d'essayer de faire
mieux tu vois c'est surtout ça et quand
tu comprends que tu es Dieu ou le monde
qui pense en toi à ce momentlà tu as
plus de colère tu es ce que tu es et à
toi de faire mieux à toi d'aider les
autres et à toi de euh d'être bon phrase
suivante en général une mère aime
davantage elle-même dans son fils que
son fils
lui-même [__] là là je sais pas c'est
une Mo niete ça ah je te laisse
réfléchir en général une mère aime
davantage elle-même dans son fils que
son fils il dirait moi mais ni tu aurais
pu le dire mais euh c'est de Nietzche
ouais [__] on est pareil vois quand je
te dis que vous avez vraiment des points
communs au niveau de la pensée c'est pas
juste une tournure c'est c'est réel il a
compris le côté organique de la femme
allez dernièrees citation pas facile
attention il reste bien peu de temps à
celui qui crée pour salir et critiquer
c'est moi oui c'est le toi et je dis pas
facile parce que vous êtes exactement en
accord sur ceux qui ont besoin de
critiquer et pour ça je vais lire
quelques citations justement qui vont
bien illustrer ça tu dis par exemple
n'arrivant pas à être fier de ce ce
qu'il est l'homme perdu se met à
dévaloriser les autres ainsi
retrouve-t-il par comparaison l'estime
de lui-même donc tu dis ça dans l'éveil
des conscience deeux là où Nietzsche
nous dit dans humain TR humain ils ne
sont pas rares c'est peut-être même la
majorité les hommes qui ont absolument
besoin pour maintenir leur estime
d'euxmême de rabaisser et de dénigrer
dans la représentation qu'ils s'en font
tous les hommes qu'ils connaissent ah
c'est exactement ça c'est la même chose
c'est la même chose mais tu sais je
pense que tous les tous les philosophes
tous les philosophes disent tous la même
chose mais d'une façon différente t les
grands philosophes mais avec les mots de
leur temps avec les connaissances de
leur temps ils arrivent tous au mêm
choses on dit tous la même chose et ça
me ça me fait venir une question est-ce
qu'on peut venir à vousout de notre
besoin de critiquer avec l'éveil avec la
compréhension que que l'autre en face de
nous c'est nous et que ça sert à rien de
critiquer l'autre c'est en général ne
pouvant pas monter on va rabaisser
l'autre
pour éviter une concurrence énergétique
et pour se valoriser auprès du groupe
c'est pas pour ça que tu seras meilleur
tu sais moi je dis toujours c'est pas en
éteignant les autres que tu brilles plus
c'est en faisant et en créant en
essayant d'améliorer le monde mais
évidemment quand tu essayes d'améliorer
le monde tu de être soumis aux critiques
de ceux qui ne font rien et c'est très
très dur oui et puis tu prends des
risques et tu prends des risques quand
tu
agis tu risques
d'échouer
tu risques d'être ou tu risques d'être
critiqué dans tous les cas c'est une
situation difficile même si tu réussis
tu vas en prendre plein la gueule la
meilleure solution c'est de rester à ta
place et de ne rien faire c'est entre
guillemets c'est l'esclave l'esclave
moderne tu vois je suis dans mon coin
j'ai ma gamelle et j'obéis tu vois mais
est-ce qu'à la fin d'une vie tu seras
heureux de n'avoir point vécu ça va être
très dur il faut quand même pouvoir se
regarder dans la glace en disant j'ai
fait ma part pour que le monde soit
meilleur pour que des hommes puissent y
vivre plus heureux avec moins de
problèmes que j'ai eu dernière question
Fred la première fois que j'ai lu
l'éveil des consciences donc le TME 1 je
me suis posé une question je me suis dit
l'éveil des consciences ça fait
référence à quoi parce que ça peut faire
référence à deux choses ça peut faire
référence au fait que nous traversons
une époque que tu qualifies d'éveil des
consciences mais ça peut aussi faire
référence à la manière dont tu es apparu
la conscience chez l'homme donc l'éveil
des consciences c'est l'histoire de la
conscience humaine qui un jour s'est
éveillé à travers tout ce qu'on a dit
dans cet entretien ce que j'aimerais
savoir c'est pour toi qu'est-ce que
c'est l'éveil des consciences et en quoi
nous serions aujourd'hui dans cette
période d'éveil bah on est aujourd'hui
dans cette prie on commence à l'être he
maintenant par les connaissances du
monde on commence à comprendre qu'on est
une unité et qu'on ait la conscience qui
est le fruit de l'évolution du monde
tout simplement et l'éveil des
consciences que ce livre montre le le
passage de l'animalité à l'homme éveillé
l'homme conscient à la spiritualité
montre que c'est quelque chose qui est
ancré au cœur de de la structure
physique même he c'est la structure
physique qui va
générer ta ta conscience et le fait de
de le savoir et de me lire B fait de toi
un homme éveillé et un homme conscient
dans une époque où don on a de plus plus
en plus par les outils technologiques la
compréhension du monde et de ce qu'on
est réellement donc on est conscience du
monde incarné en l'homme et même si nos
capacités d'analyse
augmente même si nos outils
d'observation du monde deviennent de
plus en plus précis il y a une chose qui
est atteinte et qui est indépassable
c'est le fait de dire je suis j'étais et
je seraiis
conscience c'est le point Oméga du monde
c'est-à-dire Dieu qui s'éveille en
l'homme à chaque fois qu'un homme ouvre
les yeux et dit je suis Dieu s'éveille
si tu veux et c'est la conscience la
conscience de l'homme c'est la
conscience du monde ou la conscience de
Dieu en sachant que Dieu c'est l'énergie
générant la conscience c'est le tout
mais toi tu es la conscience de Dieu
mortel et ça ne va pas plus loin c'est
le point Oméga du monde c'est je suis je
suis ici et maintenant je suis
conscience divine le royaume de Dieu
c'est le présent en dehors d'une présent
il n'y a rien le présent c'est là où
règne la conscience c'est là où trône
[Musique]
Dieu